à
[Musique]
bonjour à tous nos amis à poils et à
plumes c'est miss plume et nous vous
souhaitons la bienvenue pour ce
quatrième épisode 2 qui fait la bestiole
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
à deux petits oiseaux très coloré et
plutôt commun en captivité les
inséparables
alors avant de démarrer je vous rappelle
le principe pour les nouveaux venus sur
la chaîne mais quel effet la bestiole
vous propose de jouer le rôle d'un
ethnologue et d'apprendre à reconnaître
les comportements à bien le but c'est
d'essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe
dans la vidéo qui va suivre vous êtes
prêts c'est parti
oui
je ne sais pas
non
vous
et à présent c'est l'heure du quiz
choisi c'est la réponse qui vous semble
décrire au mieux le comportement que
vous venez de voir alors la question du
jour et me que feue la bestiole petits
tas il rajoute des plumes dans sa queue
pour la faire paraître plus imposante
c'est pour faire peur aux mâles
concurrents et protéger son territoire
petit b il se fait beau pour la jolie
femelle d'à côté c'est sûr elle va
craquer petit c c'est un employé du btp
en plein transport de matériaux
attention convoi exceptionnel
petits dés la queue des inséparables
étant trop petite pour voler
correctement il rajoute des fausses
plume pour se maintenir dans les airs
prenez le temps de réfléchir ne sautait
pas tout de suite sur une réponse sans
considérer les autres entre-temps moi je
vous remet la vidéo et on se retrouve
après pour la réponse au quiz
profitez-en pour bien noter les détails
l'environnement de l'oiseau le contexte
tout ça c'est souvent aussi important
que l'oiseau lui même
non
oui
c'était la fin
à
nous revoilà donc devant ce petit quizz
si vous voulez avoir un peu plus de
temps pour réfléchir vous pouvez mettre
sur pause là maintenant et pour les
autres on va passer aux résultats la
bonne réponse était donc
[Musique]
là c'est c'est du transport de matériaux
elle est en plein chantier de
construction bravo à ceux qui avaient
trouvé
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'avez pas trouvé pas de panique
ce comportement n'était pas facile à
deviner le seul moyen de trouver la
bonne réponse sans la connaître au
préalable était de procéder par
élimination
si vous regardez bien l'oiseau dans
cette vidéo il a l'air complètement
détendu il n'y a ni prédateur ni
concurrents à proximité et il est
complètement concentré sur son découpage
ce qui élimine déjà la réponse à ce
n'est clairement pas pour de la
compétition il n'existe pas non plus à
ma connaissance du moins d'oiseaux se
rajoutant de fausses plume pour paraître
plus gros que ce soit pour la parade
nuptiale ou pour défendre son territoire
lorsqu'ils veulent se faire plus
imposants ils font bouffer leur plus où
et car tout simplement les elfes sont
beaucoup plus efficaces et plus simple à
faire sur le moment imaginez devoir
remettre des morceaux de feuilles dans
vos cheveux tous les jours pour donner
l'illusion que vous en avez plus vous
irez seriez certainement une bonne
partie de la matinée ce qui n'est pas
franchement pratique sans compter que
ces feuilles ne tiennent pas bien et ont
tendance à tomber rapidement ce qui vous
obligerait à recommencer l'opération
encore et encore on a vu plus efficace
le fait que ces morceaux de feuilles ne
soit pas bien accroché élimine aussi la
réponse d impossible de s'en servir pour
le vol s'ils se détache au moindre
mouvement et ne vous en faites pas même
s'il ya que des inséparables n'est pas
bien grande elle est tout à fait
suffisante pour leur permettre de voler
sans avoir besoin de se rajouter des
prothèses en feuilles tous ceux qui ont
déjà hébergé des inséparables en période
de reproduction auront certainement
trouver la réponse à ce quizz car c'est
un comportement assez fréquent surtout
chez les femelles lors de la
construction du nid la femelle part à la
recherche de matériaux qu'elle découpe
aux bonnes dimensions et place entre ses
plumes pour pouvoir en transporter
plusieurs à la fois c'est une technique
qui évite les allers retours et qui
permet donc de conserver à la fois de
l'énergie et du temps et ça c'est bien
pratique alors pourquoi est ce que tous
les oiseaux ne le font pas si c'est un
gain de temps et a tout simplement parce
que les techniques requises pour ce
transport ne sont pas si simples
tout d'abord il faut savoir découper les
feuilles à l'aide de son bec même si
beaucoup d'oiseaux leçon ce n'est pas le
cas de tous ensuite il faut positionner
les plumes du bas du dos afin de pouvoir
planter les morceaux de feuilles ou
d'autres matériaux entre les plumes de
manière à ce qu'il s'y coincer qu'ils
tiennent pendant toute la durée du vol
il faut donc écarter les plumes insérer
le morceau de feuille correctement
refermer les plumes bien serré pour
tenir les feuilles et enfin garder cette
position pendant tout le trajet jusqu'au
nid si loin d'être facile et même les
inséparables pourtant très familier de
cette technique perdent souvent des
morceaux en route
d'ailleurs tous les inséparables n'en
sont pas capables il existe neuf espèces
inséparables et parmi ces neuf espèces
seuls 4 transporte ainsi les matériaux
pour la construction de leur nid les
autres les prennent dans leur bec lors
d'une expérience sur ces oiseaux les
chercheurs avaient croisé deux espèces
d'inséparables une espèce qui met des
feuilles dense et plus et une autre qui
ne le fait pas les petits résultant de
ce croisement une fois arrivés à
maturité avec les plus grandes
difficultés à transporter les feuilles
pour construire leur nid il n'arrivait
pas à décider s'il fallait qu'ils les
prennent dans leur bec ou qu'il les
loges dans leurs plus et la plupart du
temps ils repartaient sans les feuilles
qui l'avaient découpé de fait il s'agit
d'un comportement inné les espèces qui
mettent des feuilles dans leurs plumes
savent le faire sans apprentissage les
jeunes n'ont pas besoin de voir leurs
parents avoir ce comportement pour le
faire eux-mêmes lors de la construction
de leur nid c'est pourquoi même si vous
avez une femelle inséparables dit élevé
à la main donc par l'homme un pas par
ses parents c'est souvent le cas de
l'inséparable ô combien comme animaux de
compagnie il est fort probable que si un
jour elle décide de faire son nid elle
se met aussi à calais des bouts de
feuilles ou de papier dans ses plumes
sans que personne ne lui ai jamais
montré comment faire si ce qu'a pensé à
ranger vos journaux favoris ou les
sorties vos devoirs c'est au choix après
tout ce sera bien la seule fois où vous
pourrez sorti l excuse j'ai pas fais mes
devoirs monde oiseaux les a mangés et
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui si
vous avez des suggestions de vidéos à
traiter ou des questions comme
d'habitude laissez moi un commentaire et
moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouvelles aventures avec des plumes
[Musique]